-We're back with Common,
everybody.
You write about
your love of the Bulls.
The Chicago Bulls.
You write about your love
of Michael Jordan.
I did not realize this.
Michael Jordan
actually saw you play
in a celebrity all-star game.
-Yes.
-In 2010.
-And had some notes.
-Well, yeah.
Well, first of all,
I work hard to get into those
celebrity basketball games
because I love basketball.
-Yeah.
-And so many of my friends
are watching,
so I'm looking to show up
and do great.
That year, I did great.
Like, I really thought
I was going to get MVP,
and I ended up,
after the game,
going to Michael Jordan's
brand Jordan party
and he, you know, he said,
"Common, come here."
And I, you know,
gave him a little love.
And he said in my ear,
"Stick to rapping and acting."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Mike, man,
I just killed it on the court."
But not to him. Yeah.
-Yeah.
I will say,
I would have thought
that was a weird thing
to say to you
until I saw "The Last Dance."
Then, I'm like, no,
that's in line, right?
-[ Laughs ]
-Right?
He saw you as competition.
-Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
-Now, I will say you did --
you said you thought you were
going to win the MVP --
10 years later, which again
speaks to how well you're aging.
-Thank you.
-2020 celebrity game,
you did win the MVP.
Now, that's a real trophy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a real trophy
right there.
-Let me tell you.
Let me tell you.
I've received some awards,
and I'm very grateful.
But this was one
I was fighting for
for a while, man.
And I flew home
with that MVP trophy,
and I tried to take
the Michael Jordan picture.
I wish I had that,
where he was sleeping
with the trophy.
I really thought I did something
with this MVP trophy, you know,
and all my friends finally said,
"Okay, you finally did
something."
And it was in my hometown
of Chicago,
so that was a great day.
-Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
You had that going for you.
It's really good.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-I will say, um, I hope
this doesn't hurt your feelings,
but, you know, when you win
an NBA championship trophy,
everybody's watching.
I want to note in this photo,
every single person
has their back turned.
[ Laughter ]
Really, nobody cared at all.
-Nobody cared but me.
-Nobody wants to photobomb this.
Nobody wants to be near it.
-Nobody cared but me,
but yeah.
-It's like they're
embarrassed for you.
They're like, "Common's
going to take a picture."
They're like,
"I don't want to see this."
[ Laughter ]
-And they like...
I'm really celebrating,
like I did something,
and they don't give a damn.
-Do you feel like when you're
playing in one of those games --
be honest.
I would imagine you feel
like the path to the MVP
is putting up points, right?
It's not an assist situation.
-Right.
-Were you a pretty --
did you share the ball?
-Well, I was.
I'm like...
I play point guard,
so I'm a good play-maker.
And, you know, unfortunately
in those games
you just got to score,
score, score.
-Yeah.
-I scored.
But I also was getting a lot
of great assists and rebounds.
I just had an all-around game
kind of like LeBron-ish or...
-Yeah, sure.
-You know, like,
kind of, you know, all around.
[ Laughter ]
-Your humility is
coming through here.
-Yeah.
-And then we rise, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-This is something
that really is cool.
It was the 50th anniversary
of hip-hop last year.
And what an amazing
50 years it's been.
And I think the coolest thing
about when the 50th anniversary
landed is, you know,
obviously, like, every--
it's an art form now, right?
Everybody respects it.
It was sort of this
breakthrough format.
And you guys did a concert at
the Vice President's residence.
-Yes.
-And what...
It must have been so crazy
to be in D.C.,
to be at the Vice President's
home, doing hip-hop.
-Man, it's times I'm performing
and I'm like, "Man,
I would have never known
that hip-hop would get me
to this place."
We celebrated hip-hop 50 years.
It's amazing to celebrate how
powerful this culture has been.
It's brought together
so many people,
but it's been the voice of us
for a long time,
and it's continuing to be
and so influential.
I was so surprised
and loved
that the Vice President,
she really loved hip-hop,
but she really loved
her hometown hero.
His name is Too Short.
Now, if you all know,
Too Short raps real nasty,
but she like,
"But he's one of the greats."
But the Vice President loved it.
So, I was like, "Man,
this is cool that she..."
She respected the whole spectrum
of hip-hop,
not only Too Short,
but Doug E. Fresh, D-Nice,
myself, Rapsody.
It was a lot of just different
spectrums of artists
and celebrating hip-hop.
-And are you working
on new music?
Is that something
that's in the future?
-I'm working on a new album
with the legendary Pete Rock
as the producer,
and man, it's that...
-Recognition.
[ Applause ]
-I'm so -- I'm so...
I'm so enthused and inspired
about this project.
And, Seth, I'm already plugging
and saying, "Can I come back
and perform some of this music?"
-Look, I'm going to run it
up the flagpole.
I'm going to see
what people say.
No, I would love
to have you back!
-Oh, man!
-The LeBron James of rap?
Yeah, man.
-Let's go, let's go.
-You guys, right here,
give it up for Common.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go. "And Then We Rise."
It's on sale now.
We'll be right back
with Tom Hollander.